accepted 70 product
um so yeah I'm just gonna sit back and
watch you know everybody sit there line
up tears the kingdom to one of the
best-selling games
um of all time at 70 and it's going to
work because it's Nintendo they can't do
no wrong
um but yeah it is going to expose a lot
of these Nintendo guys uh and I've like
I said we've seen reactions I'm just I'm
I'm just looking forward to this well
it's okay because you know this is game
it's like it's okay because this is Game
of the Year this is quality all breath
of the wild you know it's so it's still
selling to this day like yeah
um
I gotta slow you down so so are you
implying that Nintendo based on their
hardware and and where they are that
they don't have the right to charge
seventy dollars for their games and Ed
do you think that this is a a tread that
is going to continue with first party
releases for Nintendo